welcome back to new rockstars I'm marina
masterís and today we're driving
ourselves crazy with the top mysteries
that are still lingering from the MCU
these are the things that keep us up at
night and although some of these
questions will definitely be answered in
the coming future of the MCU some might
only be answered if we keep asking so
let's ask the emcee who's top 12
lingering mysteries here we go number
one what is Nick Fury doing in space the
end of Spider Man far from home gave us
a post credit scene revealing that the
Maria Hill and Nick Fury that were
running around the whole movie we're
actually tailless and saurons Skrull
characters from Captain Marvel the real
Nick Fury has actually been monitoring
everything from space the whole time in
fact he seems to me in charge of a
pretty formidable organization out there
so what's he doing well most people
think he's working on sword which is
more or less the intergalactic version
of shield sword stands for sentient
world observation and response
Department which sounds very official
and if that's true then the actual ship
he's on is a space station that orbits
earth called the peak we'll see if this
turns out to be true moving on number
two who are the new occupants of
Avengers tower in spider-man far from
home this skyscraper is clearly being
remodeled by new tenants one of our
theories is that it's gonna be the new
Fantastic Four headquarters it's already
set up for science stuff and that would
be perfect for Reed Richards or people
also think it could turn into Oscorp
tower Norman Osborn certainly has enough
money to buy it outright
number three is Rockets origin one of
the biggest mysteries in the guardians
of the galaxy films is Rockets backstory
we know he's a highly intelligent
military tactician from half-world which
in the comics is an abandoned colony for
animals that have been experimented on
and now have human level intelligence
very much like rocket in the movies we
know some mysterious scientist gave him
cybernetic implants that left him
scarred both physically and emotionally
James Gunn is hinted that we'll learn
his backstory in the next Guardians
movie the leading theory is that he was
a genetic experiment by the High
Evolutionary Herbert Wyndham never far
does Atlantis exist
probably Atlantis was mentioned in
season 2 episode 9 of agents of shield
ye who enter here but in the movies
there have been too subtle nods to
Atlantis in Iron Man 2 on a map there is
marker in the middle of the Atlantic for
a situation that shield is monitoring
Atlantis isn't mentioned by name but
what else could it be
honestly this might seem like a tiny
detail but this exact map is how will
Conda is introduced into the entire MCU
so it's a pretty important map in
Avengers endgame Akoya mentions
underwater earthquakes off the coast of
Africa now this could be a tease for
Atlantis especially since Marvel films
don't really use any throwaway dialogue
when will it show up definitely tonight
when I'm having dreams about drowning
never vive what's the deal with the
quantum realm city and evolution effects
ant-man and the wasp gave us a taste of
what the quantum realm can do because
just being there for so long gave Janet
Van Dyne healing powers the third
ant-man movie is coming out and we've
already been shown a weird little city
in the background of a shot in ant-man
and the wasp we could say that the
quantum realm city doesn't really matter
but the time vortex is established an MN
and the wasp very much set up the
time-traveling elements and some of the
most major plot points in Avengers
endgame so the quantum realm city could
be really important number six what
happened in Budapest now we know that
this question is almost definitely going
to be answered in the upcoming Black
Widow movie it has been brought up twice
in 2012's The Avengers and again in
Avengers endgame Nick Fury also brought
up Budapest in the Captain Marvel movie
which is interesting because it was set
in the 90s but I bet this isn't my how
did I heard he have a clip-on mic it
works number seven
where is 2014 Gamora and in game we were
introduced to 2014 Kimora who comes back
with Thanos when he learns of the
Avengers plan to reverse his snap this
Gamora obviously doesn't have any memory
of Peter quill or the guardians and a
deleted scene from in-game she i'm
ceremoniously bounces in the middle of
Tony Stark's funeral because after all
she didn't know the guy so the question
is where does she go oh she's back okay
we actually talked about this on rogue
theory recently as well I pitched that
she's on Fantasy ship the sanctuary to
hanging out doing space stuff other
ideas are that she's hanging out with
Nick Fury on the peak the sword Space
Station orbiting the Earth that we
talked about in question number one
back to the list number eight where did
Luca go with the space stone
okay during the time heist in end-game
2012 Loki escaped with the tesseract but
to where well the real answer is that he
goes to his own Disney Plus series in
2021 but in the meantime maybe he would
go back to Asgard or any of the other
planets in the galaxy that we've already
become familiar with remember 2012 Loki
is still hell bent on conquering the
universe so maybe he would go on his own
Thanos lake journey to obtain all the
Infinity stones for himself or maybe
he's gonna use the space stone to barter
for something even cooler like st+
series number 9
how did Capra turn Mjolnir the ether and
the soul stone at the end of Avengers
endgame our heroes leave Captain America
to do a whole bunch of very complicated
things and for simplicity sake they all
take place off screen but the things
that he has to go do for the current
timeline to stay intact are one go back
in time to give Thor his own hammer
which he would probably have want an
explanation for to somehow put the ether
back into Natalie Portman that's also
weird to see trick her into drinking a
very red smoothie or does he like
injected into her as she's sleeping
which I definitely violates HIPAA and
number three he has to return the soul
stone to war mere wear Red Skull who is
not caps friend would probably have a
big ol problem with how he got it in the
first place never is end the timeline
did cap and up in and how did he return
as an old man there are two answers for
what happens to cap at the end of an
game after he returns from his timeline
restoring errands 1 he goes back to meet
Peggy in the early 50s and our timeline
keeps a low profile and then shows up at
the Avengers compound as the younger him
goes back in time old cap grabs a seat
on the bench
and just waits for salmon Bucky to
notice him cap makes people come to hem
witches a boss move or two he goes back
to meet Peggy in an alternate timeline
is with her until she dies and then
returns to our universe to meet buck and
Sam the writers and directors can't even
seem to agree on which one is the
correct answer so that leaves it to us
the audience to decide of course the one
I agree with is the correct answer and I
think it's number 2 I can't really buy
that Kat would go back and just be
hands-off from the 50s until now
especially considering that there's a
whole lot of wars and assassinations
that he'd probably want to get involved
with number 11 what was project Exodus
that Tony Stark referred to okay and
Iron Man to Tony Stark refers to three
different projects Pegasus
Exodus and Goliath Pegasus was the
tesseract research Goliath was the
resizing project of Hank Pym and Bill
Foster project Exodus a mystery big old
question mark theories are floating
around that it's the government secret
plan to find and extract all the mutants
in the world and put them on to colony
or it could refer to Weapon X mutant
experimentation a secret government
genetic research facility who knows not
me this is a very long list I'm only one
person and I'm doing the best I can
okay last one number 12 where has gusta
forkin been all this time in a
post-credits scene in Captain Marvel
Goose climbs up on Nick Fury's desk and
regurgitates the tesseract goose despite
being a cute little furball is actually
a fleur kin and basically has the
Santa's sack of all storage pouches
where he can keep things of infinite
size so what does Goose do after that
has Nick ferry been hiding his kitty
from his landlord this whole time will
he get his deposit back what other
things has goose eaten is he
microchipped
adopt don't shop and get your next pet
from your local shelter but give all
your orange cats a good hard look
because you never know what they could
have inside you could end up with a
whole universe on your kitchen floor and
that [ __ ] doesn't come out guys thanks
for watching everybody
what are your answers to the lingering
mysteries of the MCU tell us down below
in the comments and don't forget to
subscribe to new rock stars for all your
nerdy needs I'm very very tired so I
have to go now bye
[Music]